so Jerry you are the Commissioner of
baseball I make you Commissioner of
baseball right here right now to start
off what what do you do nothing that
anyone would like why would you say that
because they're not gonna like my ideas
instant replays over why who cares
because if you see it at home you need
to use it right if if you sitting on
your couch or something then it should
be used why why do we have a balls of
strike umpire ward we don't need that we
can easily do that with GPS
why is he that cheap eat well oh boy are
you there why don't get rid of him then
that might really happen that might
actually happen then what do you have a
robot a robot yes sir yeah is there's a
value to charm my friend there is a
value to it there we sometimes ignore
uh-huh okay so we plays gone plays gone
I do kind of like replay but if I see
designated hitter is gone so why why me
it's not baseball the one of the
essential one of the great principles of
baseball's democracy of talent and
physique this is what makes baseball
very special right democracy of talent
and physique which you can explain to
the audience what is what is that well
to me though I don't like seeing a
pitcher somehow by miracle or grace of
God eight times out of ten maybe reach
base and then put on that that jacket
which I never understand because are
they cold out the subject no well no but
that's what is the democracy of the game
is everybody plays plays it okay
everybody right so shortstop the
slugging leftfielder bomb they're all
what everyone's welcome right it's
democracy okay and pitchers hit homers
sometimes that's true now that's true I
mean that the moment Bartolo Colon went
yard was like should have been a
national holiday yeah should we have
done rid of that that's but people can't
accept perfection that's the problem
with human beings they can't go this is
fine leave it alone
right we got one decent thing just leave
it alone so why can't you have
a designator and room 1 League and one
in the other League good you'd you die
yes no I'm against nine right everybody
on the field plays the game and the game
is you hit the ball and you catch the
ball that's the game and Inter no
specialization right ok let's put up a
different hitter in this situation no
everybody that guy you're not on you're
not in the field you don't get to hit
period so we're got rid of instant
replay
it's the replay guys there you got a
third you got a get rid of what do you
think of the what do you think of just
the intentional walk like just you go to
first now no don't like that either why
it's fine
how much time you say they need about 10
seconds I mean it's 10 seconds we can
say it's like when someone texts you the
letter K instead of okay what are you
doing with that time or that I just you
gonna add that up and so you can watch
an 11 minute YouTube video of a
skateboarder bouncing his nuts off a
railing is that what we're doing
someone's texting me t why right instead
of Thank You T why I'd like to bounce
your nuts off really do you ever emoji D
emoji do you zoom oh geez on a phone I
like the symbols and not the faces okay
I won't use the faces okay but I do like
the symbols of different things I use
those okay Jerry Seinfeld here on the
show you and your special say your lefty
and so you're a left-hander did you ever
try actually no right-handed in sports
so you backed you back left and throw
right is no I don't all right and back
right okay but eating and penmanship
left where did that come from - you
everything always my ideas child did you
in the order did you ever come from did
you never bat lefty know can't bat lefty
can't do anything left
athletic okay who's your favorite
gesture left ankle teddy also is that
right yeah this hands just meet this
hand is da Vinci uh-huh and so who's
would Keith Hernandez be your favorite
left-handed hitter of all time or who
who would be there I have a little
problem with left and right and I'll
just confess it to you now I've never
noticed as someone's lefty or righty
I've never noticed where they're batting
yeah no maybe that's why you never this
batted left you just decided you just
went in the right batter's box and
that's just the way you know I think
that's a that's just a way that a lot of
people are I think I've bet a lot of
people that throw righty and pen Lefty
okay when you did Seinfeld why didn't
you choose the Mets instead of the
Yankees to put on the show to have
George work for the Mets instead of the
guys you're smart enough answer that
question why who's funnier George
Steinbrenner or the Wilpon Steinbrenner
is linearly okay
Brenner's funnier yeah and did you ever
come close to getting him actually
physically on the show we did he did a
scene in the show and it was terrible
and we couldn't use it you cut him out
we cut him out why was why was so bad
about it it wasn't funny he just didn't
have the funny Jane you'll remember
exactly what went wrong with it but it
was a quite an awkward situation where
who had to be the one to tell him that
the big eye seemed like it was Larry
call them and told them dad he had
because Larry I invited him cuz I was
really the Yankee fan right and Larry
was excited to get him on the show I
think this is a little vague okay so
which which was the best athlete that
actor acting wise that you had on the
show who nailed it which athlete was a
good actor was the best actor which
Yankee that you had on was the best
Ernie Williams no no I'm sorry uh uh
O'Neill is it O'Neill yeah cuz O'Neill
when they when Kramer says whom I
need you to hit two home runs right he
says you know it's hard to hit a home he
did deadpan and I was the best comedic
delivery I think he said something like
what the hell did you do that for like
why did you tell the kid did that I
who'd hit two like it was that old yeah
yeah I thought it was very good
well I do remember absolutely falling
off my couch on the scene where when
George's dad finally had audience with
George Steinbrenner and he used that
real estate to ask him what the hell'd
you trade Jay buna for is one of the
funniest one of the fun moments in my
baseball people said Ken Phelps to see
that on on NBC was just was just
phenomenal yeah that was the real that
was probably our best sports joke so why
do this is special why would you do what
you're doing right now go back to its
original right time to tell the story of
how this all started you know what
happens at a certain period of time is a
kind of persistence of image you know
the the successful guy you know and
that's there's more to the story and
this was just a crazy idea I had and I
just it's it's a thing for young people
to say I had no money I had no entree I
had no concept of what I was doing or
how to do it mm-hmm that's a good thing
for young people to say it's it's it I I
hope that it's emboldened to young
people on my show and you're the perfect
person to ask about this in terms of
what's right in society and what's not I
think you've got a very keen sense thank
you you're welcome Jerry on my show we
talk all the time and people actually
tweet photographs of people who take
their shoes off on a plane right what do
you think the proper etiquette is when
you see somebody who actually removes
their shoes on an aircraft it's terrible
isn't it I think it's we live we live in
filth it's a world of Filth and slob ISM
right and the only thing you can do is
try and overdress that's the only
defense in life in life just dress a
little bad
hmm you bet a nice jacket today I
appreciate that writers but you you dyed
your dances my big night you know yeah
and I like dressing up suit and tie it's
funny okay so would you say something to
somebody who takes a shoe off yeah
anyway I would probably I'm not the most
you know as a comedian I feel like I
haven't it's I'm I have license yes but
even if I wasn't a well-known person hmm
I would I would I'm obsessed with
civilities and I would sit there and
think there's got to be a way I can talk
to this person and get them to
understand that this is not okay
without angering them that would be the
puzzle I would try to solve yeah can I
do it without angering the person
certainly if you're at 38,000 feet right
yeah and then that then usually my bare
feet I mean it's okay if you have a sock
son it's not I just find it that I don't
need to be put in the position to wonder
if your hygiene is okay all together
tube public might not be the place for
you thanks Jerry thanks I appreciate it
good to see who's that the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy